what is going on guys welcome back to
the channel today we have this 2020 Jeep
Grand cherro and today we are going to
program a new key for this vehicle you
as you can see we have a blade key and
well this one has the chip inside and
also the uh the blade to open the door
but they want uh key fob to be able to
unlock the vehicle without using those
things I mean without using the
mechanical key but let me show you
really quick that this key is not
program and it says just key in ignition
but it will uh allow you to open the
switch because it's not programmed all
right so what you have to do well you
need the special equipment for this
we're going to use the autofix uh today
basically it's like an AEL uh scanner
im608 basically and well the first thing
we have to do is read the PIN code but
before even doing all this you need a
special account which is called the auto
off to be able to unlock the camway
otherwise you have to disassemble a
radio and do bypass on the cboy module
using a special
adapter but I have that account so I
don't have to disassemble anything and
well I'm going to read the PIN code
right
now
and uh the ignition is off and just
going to turn the hazards on and it will
automatically read the PIN code
um I have a b subscription for this also
you need a b subscription uh if you're a
locksmith then you will understand if
regular people like you watching this
well I'm really sorry but you have to
take this card to a dealership or a
locksm because these cars are becoming
more and more difficult to be able to
program a key because uh reasons of
stealing and all that and that's why
it's all like that so I'm just going to
wait for this tool to so I'm just going
to wait for this tool to give me the PIN
code and then we're going to go ahead
and start the programming process on
this thing people so we got the password
and well I had to use the adapter
because it was not allowing me to do it
unlocking the camway so I just have to
remove the Gateway module which is
behind this thing going to show you got
to remove the 8 mm bolts holding it this
thing sits right here like that
the connections are right there this is
the adapter I'll leave the link in the
description if you want to buy that that
adapter and well I would recommend you
to do it because it's not going to work
out if you just do the uh the gway
unlock all
right all right so I was going to say
too I have everything wired like this I
don't have the um the wireless thing so
let's just go ahead and program the key
now we're going to add the key key
guided and we're going to start again if
there's a program key you have to raise
or just press yes you already got the
code that's what matters uh check pin
code has been saved you want to reread
nope and says place an important key
into ignition make sure the it's in the
locked position so we're just going to
leave it like that and says ke ignition
but it won't turn on because it's not
perfect program so it says you want to
learn this key press yes that's the
password security code is enter make
sure it's right it is
right says come
on just got to wait a little bit
[Music]
longer and there we go guys learning
successful it says if you want to
program another one which just press
no and now we're going to check if for
ke up
works and there we
go everything working now let's turn on
the
vehicle and
boom that's how you program the key for
this 20120 well 19 20 and up Jeep Grand
cherro well you have to remove the whole
uh center console um you're just going
to need a Philips screwdriver uh 8 mm
deep socket and well some patience and
well this will be pretty much the end of
the video guys please if you haven't
subscribed to the channel subscribe
comment down below turn notifications on
well I'll see you on the next episode J
fix out bye
[Music]